now in my opinion The Prestige is one of
Christopher Nolan's strongest movies
it's definitely a film that gets better
and better the more you watch it and
it's one of the only movies I've seen
where I finished watching it first time
and immediately started up again bill
with insane details amazing
foreshadowing and a lot of things you
might miss I thought I'd take a trip
through the film to discuss everything
about it in this video we're gonna be
breaking it all down but the first thing
I have to ask is are you watching
closely so the movie centers around the
Victorian magicians Robert Angier and
Alfred Borden who watches their rivalry
escalates further and further and being
someone who exists in the highly
competitive landscape that's YouTube I'm
ashamed to admit that I've been pulled
into vicious things like this too I'm
sure lots of people have found rivalries
similar to what happens in the movie and
the characters in the film have one that
develops into an obsession
unintentionally this leads to the death
of their loved ones and them being truly
alone in the world the death of the
character's wives actually foreshadow
their own and early on they reflect the
Fate that's in store for each character
Angie's wife Julia drowns in a box and
this is of course murdered in the death
of the versions of him face if they're
trapped in the tank one of the Borden
Brothers dies by hanging and this is set
up by his wife's death arrow in the film
who hangs us up at the midpoint the film
is very much about duplicates and
mirrors with Angier creating copies of
himself in order to pull off an
impossible magic trick this is murdered
in the bordens who are revealed to be
twins at the end showing how there was a
hidden double in the movie the entire
time both use copies we just don't see
it and the two opening shots actually
spoil away that the tricks are carried
out the film opens with duplicated hats
on the ground and we later learned this
is how angia carries out his trick
immediately after this we see birds in
cages with them all being doubles of
each other similar how Borden does his
now every time Angier steps into the box
he's taking the risk that the
Consciousness he currently carries is
gonna be the one stuck in the tank at
the end and deaths like this are
foreshadowed early on this happens when
we see a magic trick being performed by
the magician the great Virgil he smacks
down on a crap with a bird making it
disappear before he brings it back Nolan
tells us the truth of this trick early
on by revealing that the first bird was
killed and the second one who appears is
simply just a double this is very much
the case with Angier who kills a version
of himself in order to have a duplicate
come out the other side making us think
he's returned Michael Kane's character
John Connor says that we don't really
want to know the truth of what goes on
in these tricks because knowing that
someone or something died would
completely horrify the audience instead
we're caught up in the Wonder and if
people knew and here was really up to
they'd all be terrified in the scene
following the bird's death we also get
the line
and this pretty much spoils the entire
twist that Borden has a brother this is
followed up almost immediately after by
boarding showing that he has a
double-sided coin probably don't have to
tell you but they're being two heads
here on one object very much symbolizes
are the two Borden brothers are playing
the one person Alfred now there's also
this idea played upon by the two women
who end up falling in love with quote
unquote Alfred Sarah calls him Al and
Olivia ends up calling him Freddy this
is because she was in love with
Frederick or as Sarah was in love with
Al but both their names together and you
get Alfred which is such a smart way to
show the two people living this one life
this is reflected in the dialogue too
during an argument start again
I love you
not today what well some days it's not
true and today you don't mean it is it
because she's with the brother who
doesn't love her this also explains why
Borden genuinely doesn't know what not
he tied on Angie's wife
[Music]
it's not that you type on
I don't know even though his wife is
gone Angier continues to wear his
wedding rings throughout the entire
movie whether he removes it just before
the trick we see this at roughly the one
hour 40 mark with him taking it off and
passing it to his assistant he does this
while it's getting undressed to make it
seem like he's trying to strip himself
down before he steps into the machine
however he's actually doing this at the
Angier who comes out the other side can
take it and have the original instead of
having a copy the machine does duplicate
clothing but I feel like Angier holds
this item higher than anything else
which is why he simply doesn't want it
to be copied now the entire movie itself
is also written in paced out like it's
its own magic trick cutter says every
magic trick consists of three parts
this is reflected in the film too and
movies are typically broken up into
three acts and the pledge is the first
part of the trick and this involves the
magician showing us an object and
allowing people to inspect it to make
sure it's all above board this is to
show us it's ordinary and it allows the
magician to take what we know to be true
and then break the rules of it this is
reflected in the film with a seeing and
you're unborn early on just as normal
men that we see the day-to-day lives of
the ordinary not really anything special
and that takes us into the second act
which is called the turn the magician
takes the ordinary something
extraordinary
this is the case in the film too with
Borden's trick being something we can't
really get our heads around even though
Kuda tells us numerous times that he's
using a double he uses a double no no no
no it's too simple this is a complex
illusion you only say that because you
don't know the method it's a double that
comes out at the end it's the only way
lastly Comes The Prestige which is of
course what the movie is named after
Kara says making something disappear as
easy but making a comeback is the
difficult part this is the final Act and
it's also reflected in the Final Act of
the movie now both Andrew and Borden
come back with the truth of what really
happened to them being revealed at the
end this is the final Act of the trick
and very much The Prestige
he said it he said it I like a lot of
Nolan's work we get the timeline playing
out in non-chronological order with us
having to figure out the pieces of
what's going on we start off with a
trick carried out by Angie and watches
Borden sticks backstage to see how it
works yeah he passes blind stage hands
who have been hired so they can't tell
the truth of what happens this was a
common practice carried out by pharaohs
in order to keep their secrets and it's
also something Kingpin adopted in
Daredevil to hide his drug operations
cut to a trial to see Borden has been
framed for the murder of Angier Julia of
course died by drowning in a tank like
this and thus I think it was chosen as a
way for him to taunt Borden Borden was
never punished for Angie's wife drowning
and Angie very much uses this to frame
him so that he gets his comeuppance in
the wings Waits Borden's daughter along
with his brother in Disguise as a man
named Fallon hate to admit it but when
first watching the movie I never paid
attention to this guy he appears
throughout the film wearing this costume
but Nolan very much uses almost camera
sleight of hand to make sure our focus
is never on him a solicitor named Owens
arrives at the prison and he says that
he represents Lord cordlow they revealed
to be Angier cordlow has promised to
look after Borden's daughter in exchange
for the secrets of the trick the lawyer
hands over Angie's diary and it's
through this framing device that we
explore the past Kurt to Angier
traveling to Colorado and he has
Borden's diary which is written using a
cipher to keep the secret this very much
mirrors the blind stage hands and shows
that they'll do anything to hide their
knowledge from other people now after
seeing that the entire town has
electricity angia travels up to meet the
real-life figure Nicola Tesla played by
David Bowie this genius had his own
rivalry with Thomas Edison who was
Notorious for trying to steal his work I
definitely recommend that you check out
the film the current War which goes over
this and the pair notorious for their
lifelong rivalry Edison's goons pop up
throughout the film and shout out to
Scott from what culture for pointing out
there during the exhibition Tesla holds
that there is the man in the audience
shutting down how his work's unsafe this
leads to people walking out and it casts
a shadow of a Tesla's exhibition later
on the film we actually see this man at
the hotel and we discover that Tesla's
lab was destroyed by him shortly after
his arrival now Angie gets brushed off
by Tesla's helper Ali who's played by
Andy Circus this might be a reach well
it is a reach but in a nice bit of
coincidental filmmaking Reddit user Dr
Mann's Planet noticed that Ali asks
Andrew what he's holding in his hand as
he walks away this is something that
mentalists would do in the 1800s and
they try and guess what was in someone's
pocket the same thing happened in The
Hobbit films between Bilbo and Gollum
which circus later played out in an
Unexpected Journey now from here we jump
back to the past to see the magician
Melton played by real-life magician
Ricky J he's gained some notoriety and
has a long-standing show with Andrea's
wife working as his assistant to the
left and right of the stage you can see
two tanks of water with dummies inside
once more foreshadowing The Twist that
happens at the end end now in the movie
you learn that and yeah is more of the
showman Raz Borden is far more technical
this is shown to us early on with Angel
lapping up being on stage and bowing to
the audience whilst Borden just strolls
up the scene sets up the tying of the
knots which ultimately leads to angier's
wife's death Borden wants to do more
complicated ones even though it's only
for his own ego the trick works
completely fine without it but he wants
to constantly push the limits of magic
backstage he talks about how Melton
never takes risks and won't even try
bullet catch which literally backfires
unborn later aborten talks about how he
has his own trick and says that he can't
sell it because no one other than him
can do it no prizes for guessing why and
they go and visit a magician named
chungling Sue a Borden instantly figures
out that the entire magician's public
Persona is in fact an act this is of
course a secret to his own trick and the
total Devotion to his art that Borden
also has chungling series spend his
entire life pretending to be someone
else which angia also brings up I
couldn't fathom with my whole life
pretending to be someone else at this
point his wife coins the name the Great
Danton for him which he hates but he
ends up adopting his attribute but then
pulled out the diary and Angie remarks
that Borden doesn't know anything about
sacrifice which we know is a lie we then
get the bird trick with the brother line
and Borden saying this
you're the lucky one today
this is something and year later Mira is
stating that day that he's the lucky one
who gets to walk away from the trick
Orton hits it up with Sarah and he takes
her home which is where the pair say
goodbye he then magically appears in her
house which in hindsight we know is due
to his brother with Karo he watches
corla wants to take all of Angie's Hall
which we know is actually him trying to
take possession of his own stuff now the
back story with cordlow is something
that shows the hypocrisy of Angie he
says that he couldn't live a lie but he
in fact is angier's real name is cordlow
with Angier being the ACT born to a rich
family he longed to become a magician
but being a performer would have brought
shame upon his family and thus he
adopted an alias now I've always
wondered if the two characters here are
also standings for the Nolan Brothers
Christopher and Jonathan Nolan have both
had their own success but it is possible
that they have a sibling rivalry in case
you don't know Jonathan was actually
educated in Chicago and he ended up
gaining an American accent Christopher
doesn't share this he talks like a
proper Cockney smoke and Angie has an
American accent whilst Borden is British
however like Jonathan it is possible
that Angier is British due to him being
a Lord and having a manner in England
Jonathan said that he initially had a
British accent like his brother but he
realized he was pretty unpopular in
Chicago because of it and he ended up
dropping it don't know what people have
got against British accents but if you
think they're all right show your
support and hit the thumbs up button and
also do it if you liked the video I
could have warns that the transported
man doesn't actually have a trick to it
and that it's real which makes it
infinitely more dangerous the funeral
plays out and could have talks about how
he spoke to someone who drowned once
old silence
tell me
who went over all but it took him five
minutes to cough
he said it was like
going home
this is something that he later says was
a lie and that it was like Agony which
is a line that still gives me goosebumps
thinking about it I was lying
he said
it's agony
at the line at the funeral might explain
why angia thinks that drowning his
copies is actually merciful at this
point he thinks it's like going home
when in reality it's a horrifying fate
for the ones dumped in the Box Sarah
reveals she's pregnant and Borden says
you're having a baby
oh my God
we should have told Fallon that is great
we're having a baby this is obviously
something couples often say but it takes
on a new meaning here with there being
two of them he talks about how Fallon
comes up with the tricks and they'll
split their earnings with him 50 50.
he's a very Enterprise and soul is uh
he's Mr Fallon so the money will come
when we get the audience yes don't worry
about it I mean I'll show off my food
with him or something we go to the
bullet trick being performed and see a
poster with lots of names in it
including Harry Dresden a huge alert to
numerous lemon on Reddit for pointing
out that this is actually a reference to
the Dresden Files Borden shows off a
trick and this involves linking two
separate rings together which might be a
reach or it might be symbolism for the
brothers being linked together as one
Andrew ends up shooting him which blows
off his two fingers and we later learn
that the Borden brother had to remove
his own in order to keep up the illusion
nice little detail in a second watch
when Sarah says
Island now Angier ends up hiring Qatar
due to him not being able to get work
because of Julia's death they also hire
Olivia played by scojo scojo in the
building now they come up with a way to
carry out the bird trick without killing
the animal Angier doesn't want to get
his hands dirty but we see how this
mindset changes over the course of the
film however Borden later sabotages this
trick damaging a woman's fingers which
mirrors how his were blown off Angie's
Act is ruined and we could to him at the
hotel translating Borden's diary in an
amazing bit of detail here on his hand
you'll see as he tucks his two fingers
in mimicking how the bordens would read
and write the cipher he States Borden
has his mind divided and broken torn
between his family life and also his
work and here is so close to figuring
out what Borden actually does for his
trick but he can't quite put his fingers
on it now he travels out to Tesla who's
played by David Bowie and one of the
best bits of casting in the film born
then starts to unveil his trick to the
public and we learn that it's called the
transport man I love the way this is
teased almost like it's its own magic
trick with us seeing the reactions first
before later seeing what happens during
it cutter instantly figures it out but
Borden can't get his head around him
potentially using a double due to his
twin being a Secret Borden buys his
family a house and we get this line I
asked you last week he said he caught me
in a wrong move clearly she was with the
other brother at this point which is
such a good line on a second watch and
your high as a double but isn't neat to
see the reaction of the people is what
pushes them further he hates hearing the
chairs beneath the stage and due to him
being a showman he craves the spotlight
the double end talks about the people
he's played in the past and namely
Caesar and Faust Reddit user Mr
Fahrenheit 120 pointing out that both
these figures weren't done by their own
ambition and this will Shadow is the
Fate that awaits and jier that night he
debuts his trick the new transported man
and he started up by making a flower
appear from his hand if you slow down
the film and look at his hand before he
brings it to Olivia's face you'll notice
that flower slips out of his sleeve
before he presents it to the audience
Angie sends Olivia and his amole but
this backfires and she feels cast out so
she sides with Borden he goes to
angier's double and does an Inception to
plant the idea in his mind that because
he's the key to the trick that he has
the power he hijacks Angie's act and
humiliates him whilst advertising his
own and here goes to Borden and Olivia
says that she's watched him closely and
there is no act andya states that she's
wrong and that he leaves props and
costumes backstage as a way to fool her
because he lives and breeds his act he
still can't see the truth though and he
burns the bridges with her before we cut
to Cutters on the floor we see two birds
once more foreshadowing the Twist and
watches born becomes more and more
famous knowing that Andrea has been
watching him he decides to walk home
alone in order to draw him out however
this is a trick to draw Fallon out and
Angie puts him in a box similar how his
doubles end up he's buried alive and the
Clones are of course dumped into a tank
while stefley conscious he gets the
cipher word which is Tesla and travels
out to America leaving Qatar behind
Borden goes to meet his wife and says
that he's celebrating because he almost
lost something very special to him of
course referencing how his brother
almost died which would destroy his
entire career and yeah finally cracks
the diary and we discover that it's all
been a trick Borden gave Olivia the
diary because he wanted her to hand it
to him and also the word Tesla would
just send him to America to waste his
time also he thought Tesla actually
cracks how to duplicate objects and he
creates a copy of Ali's cat after an
argument with his wife Angie goes to
Fallon and says that Olivia knows she's
finally figured out he's living a
half-life and she ends here because she
doesn't want to live a lie and here also
tells Valen that his daughter wants to
go to the zoo and that he should take
care however he says that if he can't
then he can take her tomorrow because
he'll of course be in the disguise
instead Tesla flees but he leaves behind
the machine so that Angier can use it
angio runs the test and he then kills
his double I don't know why he doesn't
just let the first one live and then
carry out the trick living is two people
but maybe maybe he wasn't willing to
sacrifice the way he lived for his work
he then does a reverse UNO card and the
diary reveals to Borden that he in fact
tricked him we see in the past as Angie
starts his run I love how the guy
booking the shows figures out what's
really happening but he insists that
they have to dress it up we then
discover that Sarah wanted to meet
Olivia the day before she died because
she had something to tell her she didn't
and she wants to know what the truth is
Odin tells her the truth is that he
never loved Sarah and that he in fact
loved her the entire time in hindsight
this conversation brings a lot with it
as we see how the Borden Brothers both
Loved Someone Olivia leaves him and we
witness the sacrifice once more because
both lose out throughout the entire film
Borden has been guessing andya's tricks
instantly however Ponting the final one
he can't figure it out it drives him
over the deep end and they stalk the
show watching the tanks get tailed out
every single night Borden says he's done
and to leave him alone as they can't
figure it out he says to Fallon don't go
back there but this unfortunately falls
on deaf ears and he winds up falling
into angier's trap cordella then visits
Borden in jail with his daughter and
it's at this point that he reveals the
truth he returns home to find color
there who's shocked to see him still
alive he realizes that he's complicit in
angier's execution and at the prison we
see the brothers say goodbye sorry about
Sarah
you go live your life before now right
you live for both of us these lines
obviously bring a lot with them and now
we can go off and do his own thing we
also see Borden's Prison number is d23
and Disney were the ones responsible for
Distributing the movie the cell number
d23 popped up in Civil War as well and
whether it's intentional or not it might
be the company giving themselves a pat
on the back for their convention cutter
then tells Angie the truth about the
pain in drowning and after leaving
Borden then arrives either owes the ball
at him and this was of course thrown
back to board in prison this ball was
also part of his transported man trick
and it's very much the way that Borden
returns this is the prestige and
bringing the man back after making him
disappear is cemented by the fact this
scene happens alongside of Brett's death
his final words are Abracadabra and this
magical word is of course existed in the
pantheons of magic for centuries and
centuries however it's also neatly
slotted into the film through the
character names Alfred Borden's initials
are a b and Robert angier's initial rra
put them together and you get Abra which
is a nice little touch Borden explains
the truth and why it's such an amazing
twist that I don't think anyone saw
coming Andrea also reveals to board and
what he does and the fact that he has to
murder himself the Kobe actually
believes that he's the original and in
truth we don't really know which one is
because in a way they both are the one
who isn't transported is the one who
dies and technically the copy is the one
who carries on Borden thinks he's done
this all for nothing but angia says that
it was all worth it to see the look on
people's faces as his Hideaway Burns To
The Ground we see that he's lined up all
the copies who died and this is
accompanied by the birds and the cages
from the start it's a chilling way to
end the movie but we sort of get a happy
ending with one Warden at least getting
to raise the door of the pair made that
closes out the movie and once more it
remains one of my favorite films ever
it's incredible to think that Nolan made
this in between Batman Begins in the
Dark Knight and it stands as one of the
most tightly woven pieces of sin Cinema
that I think I've ever seen and of
course love to hear your thoughts on the
movie so make sure you comment below and
let me know if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the thing which will be
linked on screen right now we break down
the entire thing and there's lots of
details in there I've not seen another
video so if you're a fan of that film
then definitely head over after this
without the way thanks for sending
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care peace